Well, hello everyone.
This is Frank Defratus.
Welcome back to another week of HoloTalk for the week of January 9th, 2000.
It was almost getting ready to say 19 something, but it's 2000 now.
We're back.
Brand new year, brand new century.
Some people would argue it's a new millennium, some people would argue it's not, but we won't even get into that.
We have a guest this week, Ikuo Nakamura, who is a holographic artist that is working out of his studio in Brooklyn, New York, does beautiful, beautiful white light transmission work.
And while you listen to the interview, you may want to click on the link to his website, either during the interview or after you finish enjoying the interview and see some of the beautiful, beautiful uh work that he's done in the field of holography.
So uh that interview is coming up in uh just a few minutes.
Uh first, there's not a lot new that's happened over the holidays uh since you know we spoke last and broke uh uh Burke for the holiday break.
Uh at the website I have something new uh that I'm going to run each week, and that's a holograph laser and holography poll where you can log on each week and voice your opinion on different topics and different subjects and related to the fields of lasers and holography.
And last week uh the first question was up, and it it went up late in the week.
It went up on Thursday, so I only have three days' results uh from that, but I do have some results, and I'd like to share those results with you.
Uh the question was when do you think holographic television will become a reality?
And here's the uh the results of that poll.
Uh five percent of the respondents to the poll said that they thought that holographic television would become a reality within one year.
Forty-two percent, which was the highest percent of all the questions, uh, all the responses.
Uh forty two percent said that holographic TV would be a reality within five years.
Thirty percent said ten years.
Sixteen percent said that it would take twenty years or more before we would be enjoying uh holographic television.
And surprisingly six percent of the respondents said that we would never see holographic television.
So uh very interesting uh little result there to that uh first survey uh poll holography poll that we had up and uh each Sunday a new question will go up and you come on to the website and uh voice your opinion and and have your uh vote tabulated.
Uh the question this week is uh should schools offer ho laser and holography programs to the students and the uh ways that you can answer that is yes at the elementary level, yes at the middle school level, yes at the high school level, or no schools should not offer these programs at all.
So uh go back to the home page if you haven't been there already and uh please take the uh a laser holography poll and I may be able to take a copy of that and put that right on the HoloTalk page so as you come on to listen to the show each week the uh poll will be right there for you and you can continuously update that and see what the uh total of the responses are as the week goes on.
So something fun to do, something different.
You know, gotta gotta have some fun.
Well let's move on to our interview.
I do have a number of people who are scheduled to come on the show for the next uh quite a few weeks actually as we go through the uh deep dark cold winter that's coming up so what better way to sit back and enjoy these uh sleek months than to uh sit back and listen to a uh show of holotal.
Well, let me get this call.
Hold on a second.
Okay, I'm back.
Sorry, I I usually turn the uh ringer off when I'm doing the show and I forgot to do it this time, so I guess I'm a little rusty from uh having so much time off during the holidays.
So yes, like I was saying, we have a lot of uh guests coming up, uh come back each week and hear a new guest and uh let's move on to our interview with Ikuo Nakamura and uh don't forget to visit his website and see some of the beautiful work in holography that he's doing.
And thanks to everyone, I also want to throw this in quickly.
Thanks to everyone who sent all those Holo Talk shows that I had lost right before the holiday season was over.
Unfortunately I had a number of shows that I had done ahead of time uh which never had been posted yet, which I have to redo.
Uh but the ones that were finished, um I now have them.
Oh this is crazy.
Can you believe this for a Sunday?
Hold on.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm not even going to chance that phone ring again.
I thought I turned the ringer off again, and apparently there's something crazy with the phone because it's telling me that the ringer's off.
Just goes to show.
All right.
Here's our interview.
Thanks for tuning in.
Don't forget tune in every week.
We've got a lot of great shows coming up.
Of course that's for you to decide whether they're great or not, but uh sh I'll do 'em and you decide, okay.
See you later.
This is Frankie Freitas for HoloTalk.
Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and I'm speaking to Ikulo Nakamura.
How are you today?
Uh very good.
Okay.
Thanks uh for coming into the studio.
Was it last week or the week before?
Yeah, but it's uh millennium, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um why don't we start out this week's interview with you by uh telling the HoloTalk listeners about how you got started in holography and when you got started in holography.
Uh-huh.
Oh yes, um actually I'm Japanese.
I started holography in Japan.
Actually, I learned in Japan.
Um I studied physics at the Science University of Tokyo in Japan.
And where I learned as a part of science.
So but it's still impressive even, you know, I study like a quantum theory and nuclear physics but uh holography is more mysterious.
It sounds like a miracle.
So anyway I started uh holography I learned holography as a science.
But actually I met art holography in New York.
Mm.
Yeah.
So it was uh like uh eight uh nineteen eighty three?
Eighty three.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's when I got my studio started in eighty three.
Oh yes?
Yeah.
So I stepped in Museum of Holography and where I saw, you know, my own year masterpieces like uh you know Dance Weiter or Ludie Balcourt, yeah Maureen.
Mm-hmm.
Uh so I was shocked because I never seen this kind of work in Japan.
So they were your early influences.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
Mm.
They still influenced me on that.
Yeah.
Still influence you Yeah, of course.
And you're your background's in physics, right?
Oh yes.
But actually I dropped out.
Yeah.
Now because of who influenced you so early on in holography, are they the reason why you've chosen white light transmission holography to work in opposed to reflection holography?
Oh yes, I I think you can say that too, because you know, uh in New York, uh just uh told you Sang or Ludie or Sam.
They are all, you know, best white night transmission holographers.
Mm-hmm.
I I learned from them.
Um you know, I c I actually I could visit them.
So I have a chance to see how they actually make holograms.
Um you white write h transmission hologram say, um rainbow hologram is like more light sculpture.
Yes.
So I really like work with light.
Yeah.
Very much.
So you know, sometimes rainbow hologram people think it's a very you know, artificial light form.
But for me, rainbow is one hundred pure natural phenomena.
Yeah.
But so yeah, that's why I I like rainbow hologram very much.
I I think it lends itself more to and of course people would argue this, but uh personally I feel it lends itself more to artistic expression uh than reflection holography.
Oh well, you know, I like reflective hologram too, of course.
But I I choose, you know, rainbow hologram as uh you know collecting light.
Yeah.
You know, great rainbow colors.
Now you've done some pulsed Ruby work on uh on a number of pieces that uh laser transmission as well.
Oh yes, recently, you know, I shoot some Ruby files at holographic arc in New York City.
Mm-hmm.
And uh yeah, I have a chance to shoot Ruby um as an artist in literature program.
Yeah.
So yeah.
That was wonderful.
You know, laser transmission holograms are actually my favorite.
Oh yes.
Always have been and always will be.
What do you think is the drawback that we do not see more of 'em?
Is is it the the fact that it's so expensive to reilluminate them during an exhibit?
I mean if you if you've shot ten laser transmission holograms, uh you're going to need quite a few lasers to illuminate them.
Is is it the cost of the of exhibiting them that uh we don't see them as much?
Uh yeah, I I I guess, you know, the one of the leasing you know, we couldn't see many laser illumination holograms.
But uh I think it now it's getting popular again.
I hope that's very yeah.
Because, you know, since the invention of white light transmission hologram or reflection hologram.
I think holographers try to make hologram by illuminating by I mean white light.
Yeah.
And uh most of us keep up or forget about laser holography.
Mm-hmm.
But I think most of us still love that, you know, hologram illuminated by laser.
Yeah.
It's a most exciting Oh, yeah, I love it.
My heart just pounds faster when I see a laser transmission hologram.
It's a shame the public uh doesn't have the opportunity to see more of them.
Uhhuh.
But actually, you know, uh I I just told you about I have a chance to shoot Ruby Power.
Mm-hmm.
I will show that speech by laser.
Okay.
Yeah, so I really don't decide to see about it.
Tell us a little bit about your studio.
You have your own private studio that you work from, right?
And is it in uh Brooklyn?
Oh yes.
Yeah, tell us a little bit about that.
Well actually I used to have my studio in Bahutum.
It's close to Times Square.
It's just one block from you know the famous Millennium Countdown place.
Yeah.
It was I I used to have the studio there, but I moved to Brooklyn and I built very long table.
Mhm.
It's uh thirty six feet.
Thirty six foot table.
Yeah, incredible.
Yeah.
But uh you know I'm really satisfied about that because I have two major benefits.
One is um actually I got other bikes from Dance Bite and Submarine.
Mm-hmm.
Because uh if we have uh enough distance from special to real the screen will be very close to coordinated.
Yes.
So I didn't have you know any coordinator length on the so you know I can get very clear image.
Mm-hmm.
And the second is actually you know I got idea from Rudy Backworth.
Actually he's doing also um I can spread uh two parts from one table.
Oh I see so you can shoot your masters and do your transfer copying without taking your setup or uh putting it up or taking it down.
Oh yes.
I think if uh it is accepting yeah you'd master and copy.
Yeah, it's nice.
Yeah it's possible at the time.
Yeah, yeah.
What what are some of your most recent pieces that you've worked on?
Um I understand a a few of them are uh not conventional type of uh ho what we consider conventional holographic work like uh the neuro hologram in the mirror.
Uh uh w what about some of those pieces?
Oh yes, um neuro hologram is uh intellective installation piece.
Um actually interlact with uh your brain wave.
So you sit down in front of the hologram and where e the brain wave pickup headband and that's what your hologram and then after it's interact from your with your you know brain wave.
If I sat there maybe something wouldn't happen at all.
Well, actually that's just a joke, sorry.
Yeah, some people you know everybody's different brain wave, right?
And brain wave is just you know, noise from brain.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
So we cannot pick up any feelings, you know, through this science, but uh it's actually interact from your brain.
So yeah, so this is kind of um how maybe you most people know about the famous hypothesis by uh pregram and both.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, hologram as a brain.
Yes, exactly.
So this is kind of you know metaphor.
Okay.
Um actually it's communication between your brain and the hologram.
Hologram at at the brain.
So it's kind of communication piece.
Um what about the mirror?
Well, mirror, you know, it's also communication piece.
You know, like uh neural hologram, um, you know, when you face uh installation, you can think about your feeling or your past or your memory and you try to find out what's happened in holography.
Mhm.
And uh mirror also same thing happens.
Uh it's also related to very personal memory and time.
I see.
That's uh uh interesting name.
Um well it's very hard to explain, but uh if you see my web page you can figure out but you know, it's how I can say.
Uh it's about time.
Okay.
You can see your own past.
Um actually a video image.
I see.
Uh C C D camera uh on the installation.
So your image will focus on space.
So you can see your own own image.
Uh it's protected by H O E I see.
And a holographic optical el element.
So well.
So essentially what you're doing in the present turns around and affects your past.
Oh yes, that's correct.
Which is actually a mirror image of how time that's itself.
Yeah, you know because what you do in the present usually affects your future, not your past.
Yes, but uh you know, we cannot change past, right?
Yeah.
But uh I was thinking about memory a lot.
Mhm.
Actually my our memory is uh past, right?
But uh you can touch past and uh our own memory is always different.
Mm-hmm.
Every people have a different memory.
Yeah.
Even in the same event.
But uh, you know, you can change um I think most people change your memory.
Oh yes.
You're neurologically rewriting your own history.
Oh yes, but I think everybody's doing that.
Yeah.
Yes.
Not real past.
No.
So you can manipulate your own past you know, in real time.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
And we will have uh just to let the listeners know there's a link to the uh HoloLab website right on the whole talk page.
So uh either while you're listening to the show or shortly thereafter listening to the show, you can click on that link and go to the website and see the works that we're speaking about right now.
Do you have any uh upcoming shows?
Oh yes.
Uh actually now I'm showing some space video protection installation at uh um canton museum of art, Ohio.
Okay.
So the title is Bridge on Into Twenty First Century.
Group shows.
Um I think it's very wonderful show.
Um many holographers from you know, Europe and Japan and showing over there.
Mhm.
And also actually uh thanks to Sharewater Foundation, um you know um we have uh artist intelligence program in Holo Center and uh you know, we are planning to show work um from next m uh March.
March.
At Holo Center.
Mm-hmm.
Um, uh Dean Hurdy and some money.
Um then next month, uh Gallery Grove and a pre Museum of Contemporary Art Arizona.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that's uh my next yeah.
So I would show the laser eliminated hologram.
And I'll make sure that uh I get an announcement out to everyone when those shows are uh going to get ready to open.
So if you want to just send me an email uh and let me know that, you know, maybe two weeks ahead of time uh uh we'll make an announcement and make sure that everyone knows that uh those events are coming up.
Oh yeah, nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh anything else you wanna let us uh know about before we uh close out the interview?
Oh no, not actually, no.
I really enjoyed I I visited the uh studio and uh Well it was a lot of fun having you here.
Oh yes, and uh, you know I found it very interesting and diodas.
Mm-hmm.
I think you know, we actually can see it's hologram and we can eliminate holograms.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's nice.
It I would like to see them used, you know, for illumination so that people would be able to see more laser transmission holograms.
Mm-hmm.
You know.
Yes.
Uh a lot less expensive than going out and purchasing uh the equivalent gas laser to do that.
Uhhuh.
Yeah.
Well, thank you very much for being on the show.
Uhhuh.
And uh stay in touch.
I'll I'll be in touch with you 'cause I know you took one of the uh the lasers back with you, so we'll have to follow up and see how that's going for you.
Uh-huh.
And uh I'll be coming in for your uh New York opening.
Oh yeah, please.
In March.
And I'd like to uh suggest that everyone head over to the uh websites that are listed on the whole talk page and uh uh take a look at all the the beautiful, beautiful work that IQ has uh has done uh over the years, spanning how many years now?
Well, I think it's more than seventeen yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, well more than seven.
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Well you take care and and thank you very much for uh coming on the show.
All right, thank you.
All right, I'll talk to you soon.
Okay, bye bye.